Speaker 1: It's great to be joined today by
Nick Lane, who's professor of evolutionary
biochemistry at University College London,
also the author of five books, some of which
I've read, including Transformer The Deep
Chemistry of Life and Death.
Really appreciate you being on today.
Thank you.
Speaker 4: Well, thank you for the invitation.
Pleasure to be here.
Speaker 1: So I think maybe to to kind of
frame the conversation.
Certain areas of science are studied in particular
ways.
Biology, for example, has increasingly looked
at genetic information as one particular way
that we study the origins of life, intelligent
life, consciousness, whatever the the approach
to that study has been a particular way over
the last several decades.
Do you think, generally speaking, that in
these fields science is focusing on the right
questions and the right approaches?
Or is there sort of like a paradigm shift
that you think would be more useful in answering
some of the key questions we don't yet have
answers to?
Speaker 4: Well, I do think a paradigm shift
would be useful.
That's not to say everything that people have
been studying is wrong.
You know, it's it's taken us a long way down
the path.
But the danger is that if you think it's only
about genes and information and so on, then
you kind of miss the broader point that there's
more to life than just genetic information.
It's kind of a statement of the obvious, but
but it's amazing how kind of how much tunnel
vision you can have in research that people
know effectively where the funding is going
to come from, the kind of things that will
attract funding, the kind of things that you
can do.
A lot of science is about what you can physically
go and do in the lab, what you know, what
technical equipment do you have to go and
explore this question?
And then I have to say, science is intrinsically
quite conservative.
And any ideas that seem to be too far outside
the box tend to be squashed.
You know, and there's lots of ideas outside
the box.
And probably a fairly high proportion of them,
probably including some of my own, ought to
be squashed.
You know, you don't squash them without thinking
about it.
You squash them after after, you know, testing
them, trying it a little bit just to see where
it takes you.
Speaker 1: Well, that's very interesting because
there are some in the science communication
community, I guess we would call it, for lack
of a better term, who often repeat and like
to say that one of the great differences between
science and religion is that within organized
religion, dissenting views are often squashed
or dismissed.
You become a pariah of sorts, in contrast
to the scientific world where actually being
able to debunk or disprove previously held
beliefs is greatly revered and celebrated
and welcomed.
And there's great celebrity available to scientists
if they're able to do that.
Is that only true in some sense or in some
cases?
Speaker 4: There is a lot of truth in that,
which is to say I won't speak for the for
the religious side of it, but for the scientific
side.
Yes, I think most scientists most of the time
set out to try and do something new, to try
and, you know, overturn the applecart to some
extent.
But the whole system of peer review, the whole
system of kind of double checking everything
and making sure that this is bona fide, that
this is solid research, that you've not missed
something obvious, that you've you've got
all the controls and all this stuff.
Well, who does the peer review?
The people who do the peer review or the people
who have, in effect, already established their
careers within establishing the current paradigm?
And so as a group of people, they are, by
nature, I mean, kind of almost by definition,
relatively conservative.
And if you really do come up with a completely
new paradigm, then you really will overturn
a lot of people's work.
And so being revolutionary is not an easy
thing to do.
I'm not saying I'm revolutionary.
I think I'm just talking plain common sense,
to be honest with you.
But.
But but this is this is something that anybody
who is genuinely has transformative ideas
in science will come up against the conservative
ness of peer review.
And it's, as I say, probably nine out of ten
people with what look like mad ideas will
really have ideas that will turn out not to
be true.
And it's probably right that they don't get
too far.
But one out of those ten maybe, you know,
genuinely brilliant, a genius who who's it?
And they face kind of problems with the social
construction of science.
Yes.
Speaker 1: To talk a little more specifically
about one of your books, Transformer The Deep
Chemistry of Life and Death.
As we kind of mentioned at the start of the
conversation, there's been a lot of focus
on genetic information in the field of biology.
And one of the areas that you explore, again,
to the extent that I hopefully understood
it somewhat correctly in the book, is about
metabolism and.
Looking at sort of the cellular level.
And when we talk about life and death, really
looking at what is it that is happening there?
Now, we've talked to scientists who specialize
in human longevity, for example, and they've
explained in a way that is relevant to that
particular field the idea of over time, the
body losing the ability to replace cells of
different types, a deterioration of sorts
that that takes place, etc., that's specific
to the field of longevity.
And the language sort of serves that, that
purpose.
Can you talk a little bit about the angle
that you take here and really this process
that's at the core that you describe?
Speaker 4: Yeah, what I'm really interested
in is, is how energy works in biology, because
it's not it's not as you might imagine, it
is actually electrical.
I suppose a lot of people might immediately
think it's electrical.
If you think about Frankenstein's monster
or something, you have an electric shock and
off they go.
And we are all our cells inside ourselves.
We have these things called mitochondria.
They're often called the power packs of cells,
and they have a they have an electrical charge
across their membrane, which is a, you know,
a trivial charge.
We're talking 150, 200 millivolts.
But if you are to shrink yourself down to
the size of a molecule and kind of stand next
to the membrane, the membrane so thin is five
millionths of a millimeter in thickness over
nanometers thick that the actual strength
of the field that you would experience if
you were there is about 30 million volts per
meter, which is equivalent to a bolt of lightning.
So this is what's keeping us alive.
And nobody imagined until a few decades ago.
This is not new information, but a few decades
ago it came as really quite a shock to discover
that effectively life is powered by electrical
charges and electrical fields across membranes.
And so for me, the interesting question is
why?
How did that get going?
It's quite a complex system.
What happened at the Origin of Life?
This is conserved across all of life.
And also, if we look across the whole 4 billion
year history of life on earth, it's pretty
weird as well.
What we actually see is the first 2 billion
years, it's just bacteria and really nothing
else.
And actually, if you think about it from the
point of view of bacteria that are still there,
they're still just bacteria.
And so we have a 4 billion year history of
life on earth, which is just bacteria.
And then at one point, which is to say all
the evidence suggests at one point you you
have the emergence, what looks like quite
an abrupt emergence in geological terms of
our own type of cell, what is called eukaryotic
cells, or that means a cell with a nucleus,
and the nucleus is where we put our DNA in
the genes.
So we have the same cell type that plants
do and, you know, mushrooms, fungi and so
on do and large single celled critters, things
like amoeba.
They also have the same cell structure.
Now, if you think if you think about, you
know, we know we've got all of these genes,
sequences from the history of life, from bacteria
all around the world.
And what it tells us is that the bacteria
and another group that look a lot like them
called Archaea, have basically explored the
kind of gene sequence space up all the possibilities
that you could have across all of evolution
from exploring different gene sequences.
They've done that much better than other types
of cell have done, eukaryotic cells have,
and yet somehow they got stuck in this rut.
They remain simple in their morphology.
They're not simple in their genetics or their
biochemistry, but they're simple in their
size and their shapes and, you know, the kind
of things going on inside.
And so it seems, I would say, that says they're
not limited by genetics, they're not limited
by the searching of sequence space, they're
limited by something else.
And that's something I think is the structure,
because what all eukaryotes have in common
is they they they swallowed a bacterium 2
billion years ago, which went on to become
these power packs, emoticons with this powerful
electrical charge across all the membranes.
So effectively they internalized respiration
in a compartment which which allowed them
to scale up, become large and complex, and
more or less get beyond the constraints that
energy has.
So obviously cells need energy, but not many
people have thought about, well, how is it
provided?
And what we actually have is we have genes
in our mitochondria and genes in our nucleus.
You need both sets of genes to control this
electrical charge.
And that's that's a kind of a shift in cell
structure, which changed the whole history
of evolution and everything that's possible.
And if we look for life on other planets and
you think, are we going to find the same kind
of things?
Are we going to find people?
Are we going to find intelligent aliens?
Whatever it may be, the likelihood is we'll
find bacteria for exactly the same reasons
that the Earth was dominated by bacteria for
most of its history.
Speaker 1: When we think forward based on
this framework, you know, I recently read
the book Precipice by Toby Ord.
Which looks at some of the more, I guess we
would say, anthropogenic risks to humanity.
And he sort of goes through nuclear war, climate
change, etc., and kind of frames the conversation
in from what we know, here's roughly how long
species last.
Here's roughly what we think about mammalian
species and takes sort of that approach to
how long might Homo sapiens last if we were
to not destroy ourselves?
But it's a very socially informed kind of
perspective when you think about the future
of Homo sapiens.
Is that side the one that seems most predictive,
or is what we're talking about here, quite
literally, how cells get their energy and
the waste of cells, which do you think as
humanity continues to would presumably advance
technologically, will bear a greater weight
on what eventually happens to humans?
Speaker 4: Well, I mean, I, I fear for the
next phase of human history.
I mean, we are very capable of doing this
up badly and effectively, eliminating ourselves
from the planet.
Now, we will not, under any circumstances,
eliminate life from the planet.
I suppose a full scale nuclear Armageddon
might just do it, but even then there'll be
plenty of bacteria left, I'm sure, down in
the crust and so on, and probably plenty of
eukaryotes down there as well.
So this transition from just a bacteria to
2 to 2 eukaryotic cells, I don't think we'd
have to go through that again.
And we've had, you know, major mass extinctions
in the past where whereas 70, 80, 90% of of
species get wiped out, you move the clock
forward by five, 10 million years and you
have a fully vibrant planet again.
So really what we're in danger of doing is
destroying ourselves and everything we care
about.
And and then the planet will readjust.
And in 10 million years, it'll just be without
us.
Would we get back?
All the majesty that we see around us is hard
to say.
It depends just how effective we are in wiping
everything else out.
So that's my biggest fear because there are
tipping points and it's it's all very well
to say we should be optimistic we can fix
any problem we put our minds to.
I would agree with that.
But we need the political will, we need the
political governance.
And, you know, we're also capable of scuppering
the best laid plans that humanity can come
up with.
And it may be we just leave it too late beyond
beyond some tipping point.
So that's the biggest threat to humanity.
It doesn't matter how long mammalian species
might normally last, we can do ourselves in
within the next 20 years or something.
Speaker 1: We're in a special, unique situation
now.
Speaker 4: Really think we really are unique
in the sense that I don't think any other
species beyond well, not even a virus could
take out the entire planet in the way that
we're capable of doing.
So I don't know that it's necessarily helpful
to think in general terms about the future.
I think we need to fix very specific problems
now.
But if if we're thinking about, you know,
if we do go into those general terms and think
about, well, can we, for example, solve lifespans
so that we live indefinitely?
I think it will be difficult.
What I mean, there's two there's two aspects
in biology that says it's possible.
One of them is that life itself is effectively
immortal in the sense that there is an unbroken
chain of cells that go right back to the origin
of life.
And those cells were metabolically active
all the way through.
So so there's no necessity.
That damage accumulates and overcomes everything.
And then there are some, you know, things
like flatworms and so on.
There's a there's a few fairly simple animals
that are, in effect, immortal and can live
indefinitely, but they're usually pretty simple.
And the things that we most care about are,
you know, our minds and our minds are incredibly
delicate structures made up of sign up trillions
of synaptic connections.
And to preserve those is a is a very difficult
thing to do.
And the decision evolution is made historically,
if you like, is how much effort do I want
to put into the preservation of the organism
compared to the replication of the organism?
And the decision for humans is, well, you
know, 70, 80, 90 years, that allows you time
to have a few kids and look after them and
even the grandparents can help look after
them, whatever it may be.
This is a kind of an evolutionary bargain,
if you like, in the bargain says you have
a limited lifespan because this is all we're
going to invest in your own prolongation as
an organism.
So we need to know the kind of the details
of the small print that says, here's why you
here's why your life is coming to an end.
And see if we can fix that.
A lot of people wouldn't want to fix that.
I think it would be quite difficult in any
case to do it.
So it's not it's not if you like, a threat
in the immediate future.
I don't think, though, you could talk to other
people who think that we already have people
on this planet who are going to live to a
thousand or something.
Well.
Speaker 1: Short.
Short of that.
And I've interviewed some of those people.
Yeah.
Aubrey de Gray has been saying for 20 years,
I think that the first person to live to 1000
is live in the limited time we have left.
It's almost cliche because it's so repeated
now and sometimes things get repeated.
And do we do they really make sense?
But there's this idea that the best we can
hope to do with standard human bodies is about
120 or 125 years, and that's beyond.
Speaker 4: Maximum human lifespan.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And so that generally makes sense to you that
until we really start making modifications
that make us not quite human, that's going
to be a very difficult upper limit to get
to get beyond.
Speaker 4: I think it will be very difficult.
Yes.
I'm not saying it's not possible, but.
But but it will be it will be difficult.
Yes.
And I think it'll take us a while longer.
I don't think we understand biology nearly
well enough yet to get beyond that limit personally.
Speaker 1: Right.
We've been speaking with Nick Lane, professor
of Evolutionary Biochemistry at University
College London.
We'll link to a number of his books, including
Transformer, The Deep Chemistry of Life and
Death.
I really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 4: Thank you.
It was a pleasure.